if you've changed your playstation plus
subscription to take advantage of its
different tiers but are overwhelmed with
what to play next have no fear here's a
rundown of the best games to play on
playstation plus for august 2022
let's kick off with the free playstation
plus monthly games for august then which
you can download and play if you have a
playstation plus essential extra or
premium subscription spoiler alert this
is going to be a very yakuza heavy video
and the first free game on the list is
yakuza like a dragon for playstation 4
and playstation 5. yakuza like a dragon
has you play as ichiban kasiga a
low-ranking member of a yakuza crime
family who takes the fall for a murder
someone else committed only to be cast
aside by the patriarch of his family and
left for dead abandoned and betrayed by
his family ichiban gets a questionable
haircut and creates a new family of
misfits who inadvertently involve
themselves in risky yakuza politics
dangerous turf wars and delightful
confectionary stores while the other
yakuza games are button-mashing brawlers
like a dragon is turn-based with the
vivid imaginations of your party members
adding a little magic to the everyday
weapons you find lying around the
bustling streets of ijincho and if you
get fed up with your current moveset a
new one is just a job change away make
sure to grab yakuza like a dragon before
september 6th
rise and grind baby your next free game
for august is tony hawk's pro skater 1 2
for ps4 and ps5 the 2020 remake of two
of the most iconic playstation 1 games
is fantastic and we here at gamespot
gave it a 9 out of 10 in our review the
game was remade from the ground up with
environments receiving a fresh lick of
paint the original 21 skateboarders have
been aged up to their current age and a
number of new faces have also been added
to the roster the soundtrack is a mix of
songs from the original games and 37 new
tracks and before you ask yes superman
by goldfinger is still on there tony
hawk's pro skater feels as fun to play
now as it did back in 1999 so you'll be
pulling off wild high-flying combos in
no time
if you're in the mood for a puzzle
platformer that'll creep you out as much
as entertain you then little nightmares
is the game for you and it rounds off
the monthly august games for ps plus as
six you need to escape the more a
terrifying underwater resort that's
filled with monsters who are on the hunt
for fresh meat it's a relatively
straightforward platformer that you'll
likely finish in a couple of sittings
but it's a creepy trip that'll keep you
entertained throughout its run time
i wasn't joking when i said this would
be a yakuza heavy episode because eight
yes you heard me right eight yakuza
games are coming to playstation plus
this year meaning you'll be able to play
all of kazuma kiryu's story in one place
i already mentioned that yakuza like a
dragon will be one of august's monthly
games and the rest are coming to the
game catalog which you can access if
you're a playstation plus extra or
premium member while you don't need to
have played the other yakuza games to
enjoy or understand like a dragon they
certainly are complementary the yakuza
series is having a real moment lately
and thanks to its recent surge in
popularity more and more people are
getting to enjoy the thrills zany side
missions melodrama fisty cuffs and
karaoke that the series offers if you're
worried about being overwhelmed by too
much yakuza have no fear the games are
coming in two separate drops yakuza 0
kiwami and kiwami 2 will all be joining
the game catalogue in august along with
like a dragon yakuza 0 is the canonical
start of the series telling the story of
the early days of hero kazuma kiryu and
how he meets goro majima in 1980's
kamarocho japan it's followed by kiwami
and kiwami 2. remakes of yakuza 1 and 2
but with a new engine extra story
cutscenes and gameplay elements like the
fan favorite magima everywhere mechanic
i'm not going to delve too deeply into
spoiler territory but the rest of
kiryu's saga yakuza 3 remastered 4
remastered 5 remastered and 6 the song
of life will be added to the service at
a later date and they are well worth
playing there's a lot of yakuza on
playstation plus this year and honestly
i'm excited for you if you decide to get
into this series now it's one of my
favorites and there's no better time to
dive in
for extra and premium subscribers july's
game catalog titles dropped a couple of
weeks ago so here's a quick round up in
case there are any that you missed first
up stray if you've been on the internet
over the past month it's been impossible
to miss clips of the adorable cat that's
the star of stray and the real-life cats
that have also been enraptured by the
game you're in the shoes or should i say
pause of a cat separated from its sweet
cat family and dropped into a
dilapidated run-down city slum along
with your drone friend b12 and the
robots who inhabit the slums you explore
the city and try to find your way back
out by solving various puzzles and
platforming around the buildings there's
also a dedicated meow button so what
more could you ask for it's available on
both ps4 and ps5
also available is final fantasy 7 remake
integrated for playstation 5 the
upgraded version of final fantasy vii
remake which stunned players when it
launched in 2020. at gamespot we gave
final fantasy 7 remake a rare 10 out of
10 and integrate packages the base game
with a bunch of extra features including
improved textures graphics and
performance mode so you can choose what
to prioritize an in-depth photo mode and
dual sense integration so you can feel
every strike of that giant buster sword
integrate also includes a new episode of
the story intermission where you can
play as the cutest ninja around yuffie
if you're waiting for final fantasy 7
remake part 2 or want to experience the
story for the first time integrate is
the perfect way to do both
if the recent news of marvel's phase 5
has you hyped give marvel's avengers a
go on playstation in single player you
can play as some of the earth's
mightiest heroes as they battle evil
criminal organization aim and in
multiplayer you can level your
characters and take them online new
heroes like the mighty thor and black
panther have been added since launch
with more reportedly on the way the
game's multiplayer can certainly be a
bit of a grind but it's still enjoyable
with some pals and the single player is
a fun snappy story about heroes who have
lost confidence in themselves and the
journey to reuniting them as a team
if you fancy digging into some history
and making it your playground try some
assassins creed on for size a number of
ubisoft's flagship games are in the game
catalog including the ezio collection
rogue remastered and my personal
favorite assassin's creed iv black flag
where you can take to the high seas as
pirate edward kenway so if you're
waiting for the next mainline
installment of assassin's creed well
there are hundreds of hours of games
here for you
and finally a pick from the classics
catalogue which is available to premium
subscribers if you missed tokyo jungle
when it originally launched on
playstation 3 you can find it here tokyo
jungle is a throwback to classic easy to
pick up and hard to put down gameplay
with a quirky and brutal twist humankind
has gone nature has reclaimed the land
and all the animals are so so vicious
you can control everything from a tiny
little pomeranian to a majestic lion and
your goal is simply to survive it's kill
or be killed out there on the streets of
tokyo so that cute pomeranian has to be
bloodthirsty to live another day yes
tokyo jungle is brutal but it's also
very funny and a wonderful little gem
that would otherwise be lost to time so
give it a try if you've got premium
those are our picks for games to play on
playstation plus this month there are
hundreds of games on the service and the
catalogs are constantly changing so make
sure to subscribe to find the best games
to play to get the most out of your
subscription let me know what you'll be
playing in the comments below or
highlight some games you think deserve
more love i'm on twitter at lucy james
games and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you